dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly zsolnai-fehér
this piece of work is about reducing the
time needed to simulate elastic
deformations by means of pre-computation
okay so what does the term
pre-computation mean if we are at an
open book exam and we are short on time
which is basically every time it would
be much better to do a pre computation
step namely studying at home for a few
days before and then when we are there
we are endowed with quite a bit of
knowledge and are guaranteed to do much
better than trying to grasp the simplest
concepts on the spot this
pre-computation step we only have to do
once and it almost doesn't matter how
lengthy it is because after that we can
answer any question in this topic in the
future
well sometimes passing exams is not as
easy as described here but a fair bit of
pre-computation often goes a long way
just saying the authors have identified
three major bottlenecks in already
existing pre computation techniques and
proposed optimizations to speed them up
considerably at the cost of higher
memory consumption for instance the
algorithm is trained on a relatively
large set of training post examples if
we don't have enough of these training
examples the quality of the animations
will be unsatisfactory but if we use too
many that's too resource intensive we
have to choose just the right amount and
the right kinds of poses which is a
highly non-trivial process note that
this training is not the same kind of
training we are used to see with neural
networks this work doesn't have anything
to do with neural networks at all the
results of the new technique are clearly
very close to the results we would
obtain with standard methods however the
computation time is twenty two two
thousand times less in the more
favorable cases computing deformations
that would take several hours can take
less than a second
that is one draw trapping result and a
hefty value proposition indeed this
example shows that after a short
pre-computation step we can start
torturing this poor armadillo
and expect high quality elastic
deformations and there is a lot of other
things to be learned from the paper
gram-schmidt orthogonalization augmented
krilov iterations Newton PCG solvers
essentially if you pick up a dry
textbook on linear algebra and for every
technique you see there you ask what on
earth this is useful for you wouldn't
have to go through hundreds of works it
would find a ton of answers in just this
one absolutely amazing paper also please
don't forget that you fellow scholars
make two minute papers happen if you
wish to support the show and get access
to cool perks like an exclusive early
access program where you can watch these
episodes sixteen to twenty-four hours in
advance check out our page on patreon
just click on the icon with the letter P
at the end of this video or just have a
look at the video description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
[Music]